once you've mastered your multiplication
table up through
10 you can multiply any two one-digit
numbers together
our next step will be to multiply
two-digit and three-digit numbers
by one-digit numbers we call these
problems
two by ones and three by ones
as we'll see two by ones and three by
ones are the
essential building blocks to all mental
multiplication problems
once we've mastered those skills we can
move on to multiplying
any two-digit numbers in fact we'll see
at the end of this lecture
that many two-digit multiplication
problems can be turned into
two-by-one or three-by-one problems
we know how to multiply one digit
numbers by numbers below
20 so let's do some bigger problems
we'll start with a very very simple
two by one 20 times 7
or equivalently 7 times 20.
so we start by doing 7 times 2
which is 14 so we instantly get
7 times 20 is 140.
that was just a warm-up problem all
right now let's try a more complicated
one
let's try the problem 23 times
7. all right we start with 7 times 20
which is 140 then we do 7
times 3 which is 21.
add those together 140 plus 21
and we get from left to right 161
okay let's try another one let's try 87
times eight we start with eight times
eighty well eight times eight is
64. so 8 times 80 is
640 good then we do
8 times 7 which is 56.
now we add them together from left to
right
640 plus 56 that's 600 and what
40 plus 56 is 96
and there's your answer 696.
now what we've drawn here looks like
what we do on paper
but it's a little different in that here
we see the bigger number
first here let's let's do a few more
problems i'll start with one
that i think is especially easy let's do
53
times six okay so six times
50 is what 300
in fact i want you to say it say it 300
the reason we can say it is that the
answer is
not going to change to 400 there's no
way it can
that can happen why because i'm about to
add a one digit times one digit problem
those can't get any bigger than nine
times 9 and that's less than 100
so i can say 300 with complete
confidence
next we'll do 6 times 3 which is
18 go ahead and say it and now you've
said 300 318
you've said your answer 318.
okay you try 87 times 5
5 times 80 is 400
you can say the 400 so do it 5 times 7
is
35 say it 435
is your answer okay let's try some
harder ones
the next one's a little harder because
it has a carry
but it's still not too bad let's try the
problem
28 times 9. all right we start with
9 times 20 9 times 2 is eighteen so nine
times twenty is
one hundred eighty next we do nine times
eight which is
seventy-two now the hard part one
hundred
eighty plus seventy-two i know that's
going to carry so i'll start to say
200 and adding 80 plus 72 that's 152
so there's the rest of the answer 52
252. now
it took me about a minute to explain
that but trust me
with just a little practice you can
calculate
any two-digit times one-digit problem in
just a few seconds
okay you try this one find the area of
this triangle
it has a height of 14 inches it has a
base of 59 inches
we know that the area of a triangle has
the formula
one half base times height so
i have to calculate one half times 59
times 14. but since i can multiply
numbers in any
order that's called the commutative law
i'll do one half times 14
times 59 because half of 14 is
7 so the problem simplifies to
7 times 59 okay how are we going to do 7
times 59
we'll start with 7 times 50 which is
350 then 7 times 9 which is
63 350 plus 63 let's do that from left
to right
i see a carry coming it's going to be
400
and 50 plus 63 is 113
so there's the answer 413
square inches in our triangle
here's another way to do the same
calculation
59 times 7 that you might find even
easier since 59 is
60 minus 1 we could treat this problem
as 7 times 60
minus seven times one
right seven times sixty is
four hundred twenty and now all i have
to do is subtract
seven four hundred twenty minus 7 is
413 and that's your answer
instead of doing a hard addition problem
we did an easy subtraction problem
here's another problem that can be done
two ways
let's try the problem 78 times
four using the addition method
we can do that by taking 4 times 70
which is
280 right 4 times 7 is 28
so 4 times 70 is 280
then we do 4 times 8 which is 32
280 plus 32 28 plus 3
is 31 so i have 312
as my answer now let's try and do that
problem
using the subtraction method here we'll
treat 78
as 80 minus 2 so we'll do 4
times 80 then subtract 4 times
2. 4 times 80 is
320 minus 4 times 2
that's 8. 320 minus
8 say the 300 if you will is
312 and that's your answer
so which method should you use
at this stage of the game i recommend
that you do it
both ways this way if you get the same
answer both times
you can be pretty certain that the
answer is right
here's how i recommend that you practice
in the beginning
it's very helpful to be able to see the
problem
your goal is to solve the problem in
your head
without writing anything down but if you
don't have to remember the problem
then that will make it easier on your
memory for example
when you work through the problems in
the course guidebook
go ahead and look at the problem as you
calculate the answer in your head
but once you're done with those create
problems on your own
where you only let yourself see half of
the problem
a calculator can come in handy for this
in fact
here's what i do let's take the problem
3 times 87
we'll bring out a big calculator alright
so with the calculator
you might type 3 times 87
but before you hit the equals button
don't do that until you have the answer
now the calculator is allowing you to
see
87 but not three okay
for a greater challenge you could
instead do
87 times three now you can see the
three but not the 87. eventually you'll
do the problem
without seeing any of the numbers and
don't don't hit the equals button until
you have the answer
240 plus 21 261.
so why should 3 times 87 be the same
as 3 times 80 plus 3 times 7.
the short answer is that this is called
the distributive law
and the rules of arithmetic are defined
to obey
this law but here's a more intuitive
explanation
if we have say three bags of marbles
and each bag has 87 marbles then how
many marbles do we have
well by the very definition of
multiplication we have
3 times 87 marbles
but now suppose i tell you that in each
bag
80 of the marbles are blue and seven of
the marbles
are crimson now how many marbles do i
have
the answer is still 3 times 87
but we could also say that the number of
blue marbles
is 3 times 80 and the number of crimson
marbles
is 3 times 7 so the total number of
marbles
is 3 times 80 plus 3 times 7.
which answer is right they're both right
so they must be equal 3 times 87
is 3 times 80 plus 3 times 7.
another way to see the distributive law
is by drawing a picture okay
look at this rectangle it has a height
of a
and a width of b plus c so what's its
area
well on the one hand it's a times b plus
c
on the other hand if we look at the area
of one
rectangle inside of it has area a
times b and the other rectangle inside
of it
has area a times c so the total area
would be a times b plus a times
c therefore both quantities are the same
the same logic applies to larger
multiplication problems
like seven times three hundred twenty
four
imagine seven bags each containing three
hundred blue marbles
twenty crimson marbles and four dark
green marbles
the total number of marbles is seven
times 324
but it's also equal to seven times three
hundred
plus seven times twenty plus seven times
four
so they must be equal and on that note
let's start multiplying three digit
numbers by one digit numbers which i
call
three by one multiplication
naturally you'll be you'll need to be
good at doing
two by one problems before you can
master three by one problems
on the other hand practicing three by
ones is a great way to improve your
ability to do two by ones
so let's move on as we'll see
two by ones and three by ones are the
building blocks
for all mental multiplication problems
so we want to be comfortable with them
again we'll start up with a very simple
warm-up problem
300 times 7 or equivalently
seven times three hundred all right so
since seven times
three is twenty-one we instantly get
seven times three hundred is twenty one
hundred
okay as i said that was an easy one
here's another problem
that's almost as easy as a two by one
let's do 320 times
seven okay so this time we know that
seven times three
hundred is still twenty one hundred
next we do seven times twenty which is
one hundred forty now i want you to
listen to the numbers
twenty 2100 plus 140
is 22 hundred
and 40. the word hundred lines things up
not so much in your eye but in your ear
2100 plus 140
is 2240.
now let's take this one step further
let's try and do 320
times seven it starts off the same as
before
we start with seven times three hundred
to get twenty one hundred
then we do seven times twenty which is
one hundred
forty add those together to get 2240
but notice that we added those together
before we took the third step of doing
seven
times four so i've got 2240
now i add 7 times 4 which is
28 2240 plus 28
go ahead and say the 2200 if you will 40
plus 28
is 68 and there's your answer
2268. that was hard the first time i
know
let's do another example here's a
question
how many days occur in a six year period
all right so we'll start by doing the
problem 365
times six okay so what do we do
we start with six times 300 which is
eighteen hundred now folks another
virtue of working from left to right is
that we
now know that our answer is a little
bigger
than eighteen hundred right i mean if i
were doing this problem from right to
left
all that i know is that my answer ended
in
zero but by working left to right i know
that my answer is a little bigger than
1800 and it's way more important to know
that you have an answer that's a little
bigger than 1800
then to know that your answer ends in
zero
so by working from left to right we're
working with the most significant digits
right from the start okay but let's get
the exact answer anyway
next we'll do 6 times 60
which is 6 times 36 is 36 so 6 times 60
is
360. okay now at this point you want to
stop
and add 1800 plus
360. 1800 plus 360
is 2160.
good next we do 6 times 5 which is
30 add those numbers before you forget
them
2160 plus 30 is 2190
and that's the answer well actually
that's the answer to the multiplication
problem
for the original problem we'll have to
add 0 1 or two
depending on the number of february 29th
among those six years
by the way as we'll see later you can
get zero leap years in a six year period
when covering a year like eighteen
hundred or nineteen hundred
anyway you've now seen everything you
need to know
about doing three digit by one digit
multiplication
naturally some problems are easier and
some are harder
but the basic idea is always the same
we calculate from left to right and add
numbers
as we go let me give you a few more
problems i'll start with
with an easy one and then we'll work our
way up to some harder ones
all right this one's very easy try to do
the problem
402 times nine
okay so we'll start with nine times 400
which is 3600 go ahead and say
the 3 600 you can say it because all
you're going to be left with
is 9 times 2 so that 3 600 can't
possibly change
3 600 next we do 9 times 2 which is
18 say the 18 and you've said your
answer
3618.
another good reason to work from left to
right
is that you can often just like in this
problem
you can often say your answer while
you're still
calculating not only does that help your
memory
do the problem it also gives the
illusion that you're doing the problem
even
faster and that's a good thing now what
made this problem
most most convenient was that juicy 0
in the middle of the problem sometimes
having a 1 in the middle of the problem
also makes things easier like in this
next problem
let's try 812 times three
we start on the left with three times
800 which is
2400. now go ahead and say the 2400
i know that 3 times 12 is going to be
under 2 400 is going to be under 100
so i can say 2400. next we do 3 times 12
which is
36 and there's your answer 2436.
here's another problem where you can say
the beginning of the answer
without any risk of having to correct
yourself it's when we have the number
five interacting with an even number
let's do 527 times eight
so here we have eight times five hundred
which is
four thousand go ahead and
say the four thousand there's no way
that what comes next
is going to make that four thousand
change into a five
thousand right because what comes next
is always less than ninety nine times
nine
that's less than a hundred times ten
that's less than a thousand so you can
safely say
four thousand get it out of your memory
now you do 27
times eight now that's a two by one
problem we can
we've simplified our life to a two by
one problem eight times
twenty is one sixty eight times seven is
fifty six
160 plus 56 is 216
and there's your answer 4216.
all right here's another easy one let's
do 925
eight all right so we'll start with
eight times
nine hundred which is seventy
two hundred now what what's coming next
after the seventy two hundred you can't
say the 7200
but look what's coming next 25 times 8.
now i happen to know that 25 times 8
is 200 right if i've got eight quarters
in my pocket
i know that that's two dollars and if
you if you know
if you know something don't be afraid to
use it eight times 25
is 200 add that to the 7200
and you have 7200 plus 200
is 7400 okay
let's try a harder problem let's try 789
times seven all right so we start with
seven
times seven hundred which is forty nine
hundred
seven times 80 is 560.
add those together from left to right
listen to the numbers
4 900 plus 560
is 5460
next we do seven times nine which is
sixty three
we're going to have to do fifty four
hundred sixty plus sixty three
now don't panic what you can notice
right now is that there's going to be a
carry
so relieve your memory by saying 5500
right now that 5400 becomes a 5500
now do 60 plus 63 that's as easy as 1 2
3 123 so you know how the answer ends
with 23. so there's your answer 5523
but there was another way of doing that
last
problem 789 times 7 that you might
find easier notice that 789
is 800 minus 11.
because of that we could do this problem
as seven times eight
what's 5600 minus 77
you know it's going to be 5500 and
something
5500 and what well the complement of 77
is 23 so there's your answer again
5523
as we've seen before we've taken a hard
addition problem
one that had lots of carries and turned
it into
an easy subtraction problem
once you've mastered two by one and
three by one multiplication
you can actually do most two by two
multiplication problems two digit times
two digit numbers
using what i call the factoring method
most two digit numbers can be factored
into smaller numbers as a matter of fact
69 of the 92-digit numbers more than
two-thirds of them
can be factored into smaller numbers and
we can often
take advantage of this for example
consider the problem 23 times 16.
now when i see 16 i can't resist
thinking of 16
as 8 times 2. so for me
when i do 23 times 16 i want to do 23
times 8 times 2. so that's going to be
our strategy first multiply by 8
then multiply by two you can even hold
that two on your fingers
on reserve if that helps you remember it
okay
let's do 23 times eight
all right 23 times eight that's a two by
one
eight times 20 is 160
8 times 3 is 24 160 plus 24
is 184 good pause take a break you're
halfway there
what do we do with that 184
we multiply it by the 2 you were holding
on to right
184 times 2. if i double 184
or use the 3x1 methods we've learned we
get 184 times
2 is 368. so our original problem
23 times 16 is 368.
by the way the reason that 23 times
8 times 2 is the same as 23 times 8
times 2 is due to what's known as the
associative law of multiplication
but let me show you another way to do 23
times 16.
i said 16 is 8 times 2 you could also
say
that 16 is 2 times 8 the same thing
not really because 23 times 16 we could
now do
as 23 times 2 times 8.
maybe you'll find that easier 23 times 2
is 46 and when you multiply that by 8
46 times 8 is 320 plus 48
is 368. this way you didn't have to do
any 3x1 multiplication
or maybe you'd rather think of 16 as
four times four 23 times 16
is 23 times four times four
23 times four that's a two by one eighty
plus twelve
is ninety two when you multiply that by
four
we have three sixty plus eight we get
three sixty eight okay let's do another
problem
suppose that your phone service costs
you 59
per month how much will that cost in a
year
all right so we can break up the number
12 lots of different ways
let's break it up as 6 times 2 so we'll
do
59 times 6 times
2 so we do 59 times 6 what's that
that's an easy two by one it's 300 plus
54
354 and now we multiply that
by 2. 354 by 2
is a not too bad 3 by 1 problem
because 2 times 350 do that all at once
is 700 and 2 times 4 is
8. so there's your answer 708
dollars one last problem
suppose a swimming pool has dimensions
14 feet
by 14 feet by seven feet deep
what's the volume of the pool okay well
the answer of course is 14 times 14
times 7
cubic feet let's do that multiplication
in our head
starting with 14 times 14
which we'll do a few different ways one
way
of doing that problem fourteen times
fourteen is to break fourteen into two
times seven
so now you have fourteen times two times
seven
which is twenty eight times seven and
twenty eight
7 that's 140 plus 56
is 196. another way of doing 14 times 14
is you could do 14 times 7
times 2. 14 times 7 is 98
and when you double 98 you get 196.
or we can use the method we learned in
lecture one
for multiplying two numbers between 10
and 20 right we're doing 14 times 14
let's not forget what we learned in
lecture one we can do that by taking
14 plus 4 which is 18
multiplying that by 10 to get 180
then add to that 4 times 4
16 to get 196.
okay so the original problem 14 times 14
times 7 becomes 196
times 7 which we can also do in a few
different ways
using the addition method we can do 196
times
7 by doing 7 times 100
hundred seven times ninety six hundred
thirty add those together to get
thirteen hundred
thirty then do seven times six forty two
add those together thirteen hundred
thirty plus 42
to get 1372 cubic feet
or you could do it by subtraction
you could take 196 times 7 and take
advantage of the fact
that 196 is 200 minus four
seven times two hundred is fourteen
hundred subtract seven times four
fourteen hundred minus twenty eight is
1300 and what the complement of 28
is 72 so there we have it again
1372 cubic feet
to summarize this lecture i've shown you
everything you need to know to do two by
one
and three by one multiplication which
are the most fundamental operations
of mental multiplication for most of
these problems
you'll use the addition method but
sometimes you may find it faster
to use subtraction with just a little
bit of practice
you can do any two by one or three by
one problem
in just a few seconds and now would be
an excellent time
to practice with these skills under your
belt
you can even multiply most two-digit
numbers together
we'll have plenty more to say about
mental multiplication techniques in this
course
but before we do that we'll attack the
fourth of the fundamental operations of
arithmetic
so get ready to divide and conquer
[Music]
you